how does that feel winning that in the
last race of the season last lap as well
sliced
insane like if you would say that before
the season or even
with a few races to go you would be like
that's mental like
you can you cannot imagine like even the
night before i would not imagine
something like that so i hope it never
happens again
checko is better at karaoke than max
three two one really yeah
yes the voice of an english i'm really
bad you you you must be totally
you
hear him sing he's amazing
i mean
i will only do it once i have a couple
of drinks
i i enjoy it actually but i know that
i'm terrible at it no he's very good
he's just being shy can you give us an
example
no way
absolutely not i mean i've seen him in
tokyo it's
it's impressive
i'm sure you can't remember that one
can you
[Laughter]
marco should be removed from the formula
one
calendar wow we are agreeing again
[Music]
no way
monaco is history it's
i think a lot of us grew up
looking at the race in monaco you know
on tv and and it's the most special race
you can ever race in in
in the calendar apart from your home
grand prix i think there is no other
place that you dream of driving
of racing than other than monaco you
know so
it's pure history of our sport is there
anywhere you'd like to see added to the
formula in canada maybe somewhere you
haven't raced before
south africa
i think it's good to race it's coming
yeah i hope so yeah what is it that's
not that'll be quite about the idea well
i mean when you look at the continents
where you race i think we definitely
need to try and you know pursue a bit
more into africa and at the moment which
looks like most likely place to go to
south africa because they already have a
track and they've been there before
formula one should introduce a salary
cap
three two
th this is it
for me it's insane because it's not only
hurting us like
in f1 but nowadays like so many drivers
are either backed by an f1 team or by
personal sponsors who are investing in
these young drivers careers but of
course they also expect a return or at
least a percentage of their future
income
but if you start to cap their future
income they're not that interested in
supporting them throughout all the
categories and nowadays it's so
expensive going through all the
categories before you even get to
formula one that it will hurt a lot of
the lower categories yeah for me it's
very unfair you know that the sport now
in general is booming everyone is making
a lot more money including of course the
organization the teams
and then everyone is becoming profitable
and then suddenly the drivers will
actually make the show and risk their
lives and they're of course you know
their lives let's take it while driving
they should they suddenly should be be
capped and for me that just makes no
sense
the drivers are the one
risking their lives out there putting
the show together you know
and the sport is hard best you know
everyone is making
the most money ever so why you should
cut the drivers i don't think it's
correct i'd rather win a world
championship in the final race of the
season
than with a few races to go
three two one
but as long as you win
it doesn't matter ah go here because
i've done one
now i hope to do the other one so then
let's board
but how does that feel winning that the
last race of the season last lap as well
it's like
insane like if you would say that before
the season or even
with a few races to go you would be like
that's mental like
you can you cannot imagine like even the
night before i would not imagine
something like that so
i hope it never happens again
like i never came up in my mind that i
would be fighting in the last lap
for for the championship last race as
you can imagine it happened in the past
but last lap
yeah how were you nervous at the time
quite a bit yeah i'm normally not a
nervous guy but that last night because
you knew that you had to nail it to to
go for it and have a chance to pass um
so yeah you were definitely a bit
nervous you you also talk to yourself
like this is your chance and you have
lived for that moment you know to be
able to fight for a championship your
whole life or
at least
yeah
for me it was
almost 20 years you know so
you also tell yourself this is it you
have to go for it you know so it's like
two different kind of
feelings and emotions you have very very
quickly in uh behind each other like in
a
second and then you just like focus on
on your driving again
the netherlands
will win the 2022 world cup
three two
one
ah sorry
i have to be positive
i mean you have to have the positive
attitude going into the tournament you
have to believe that you can win it
otherwise what's the point of even going
that's a good point
but you're not playing it so i
am i hope they believe that as well
because i mean what's the point
otherwise you play you get tired for
nothing i just don't think that they has
a
the team you you don't have your best
team
yeah well i mean yeah so
the world championship the one that you
kicked us out do you remember they were
with the yeah when you when the penalty
yeah
when your defender was too aggressive
how do you think mexico are going to get
on this world cup i'm also not too
positive on that one to be honest
yeah
but i hope i'm wrong
and we go very far what do you think
about england's chances do you think you
could come home i hope we finish in
front of england
yeah
i think they had their best shot at the
euros yeah
i hope people don't hate me
i'm honest you know so
i'm not gonna lie
i think they're better teams
who joking was gonna win the world cup
holland
i hope brazil i hope
oh really jesus made that's quite a
statement well they have a very good
team
you know i think they have very good
chances
i wish mexico but i don't think
i'm france obviously you're going to be
very strong
don't you don't you think holland is
winning it
you should be rooting for brazil
it goes like this holland if they are
kicked out belgium if belgium is kicked
out i'll switch to brazil and then
mexico
yeah then yeah brazil's out
i might think about supporting mexico so
how far down your list is england very
much
it's all on the list i mean you cannot
support i mean i already like holland
belgium then you switch to brazil brazil
mexico i mean where is it going to end
like
i'm going to support the winner or
whatever
max is a better prankster than
three two one
he is a prankster
he he definitely is he's doing it a lot
to like family members or like trainers
i like to practice
last year i got badly pranked i got
at the same time it was like within a
week that they prank marketing practice
so i was like and then i went to mexico
and i was like i have to do something
so i
i found some
ichi powder and i put it all around the
the margarita
in the back like the seat the bags the
jackets like the t-shirt but i did it on
a
thursday
so for the entire weekend i was just
chilling like for a couple of hours but
then they were like
for the whole weekend you could see
everywhere like
it just gets worse because you're like
spreading it everywhere you know so it
was amazing i just really heard that you
wrote yourself as a friend to compare i
don't really know
i don't really like pranking right well
i i i don't like to get pranked but then
i'm like
i also come here a student prank someone
back
i don't know i'm like just let it go
i love being teammates with a person
opposite me three two one
look at that
okay we can agree on something
i think
sometimes in the past i've had like
some jealousy you know from from a
teammate because you obviously want to
win but when the guy next to you wins
you have to give the credit and you know
he's on better than you he's he's won
and
you have to accept that
and i also feel
proud you know of of what he's done you
know the guy next to you and i think
not many people
can take it but i think within us you
know when i win when max wins there is
always
like we feel proud of each other and
that's something i think is is good
within us i i started of course very
young in formula one and i had a
i think also a very good relationship
with daniel but at the time i was still
like 18 19 and i think where i am now as
a person is completely different so i
would say that yeah what i have now with
checker is definitely the best just
because
i matured a lot and i think that also
helps a lot with just how you approach
each other i think when you were younger
you were a bit more difficult
oracle red bull racing are the best team
in formula one
three two one
i've been a part of the team now since
uh 2016 and of course i also like um
signed until
and it's just you know a great group of
people all the time yeah
i'll be 21.
nearly the same age
it's crazy to think about that people
always
you know so focus on the performance
side that they actually forget to have
fun at the same time where i think here
at the team you know we do a lot of fun
things but also you can have a laugh you
go for dinner and you build up a great
relationship over the years as well with
a lot of team members
yeah i think it's a great team because
it's a team that has a lot of fun out of
of racing
but also is very focused when when we
are doing our job has good relationship
there's a great atmosphere within
the mechanics engineers
not so much the marketing team but the
rest of them
[Laughter]
cheers mate cheers man that was fun
have you seen this before
no no first time yeah i've seen it
before i i followed them on on instagram
so
which one did you see before max the the
one with chris hemsworth and uh i
struggled to say his name all the time
yeah taika
yeah
he has a bit of a complicated name yeah
what did you think of it i i think i
thought it was nice at the time i
watched the whole thing so
well done
good job
yeah
sorry i just heard some phone
stuff if
you guys got a phone in your pocket are
you vibrating
but that might be another thing
[Music]
captain america has the best suit of any
superhero it's not the truth it's the
suit for him
and it works for him but if we're
measuring against all the avengers let's
be honest it's not the best